si se le ha diagnosticado niveles altos
de colesterol a usted oa alguien que
conozca es importante que lo mantenga
bajo control este vídeo muestra algunas
maneras de ayudarlo a controlar su
colesterol como dietas ejercicios y
medicamentos
si sus niveles de colesterol están
demasiado altos es importante que tenga
una dieta que sea saludable para su
corazón para tener una dieta que sea
saludable para su corazón usted debe
comprender como los tipos de grasa que
consume pueden afectar sus niveles de
colesterol por ejemplo las grasas
saturadas las grasas hidrogenadas y las
grasas trans tienden a elevar los
niveles de colesterol malo también
llamado colesterol de lipoproteína de
baja densidad o ldl en su sangre estas
grasas se encuentran en la carne y en
los productos lácteos en aceites
tropicales y en varios alimentos
procesados como pasteles y galletas
y reemplazar las grasas saturadas por
insaturadas puede ayudar a reducir los
niveles de colesterol malo en su sangre
cuando se consumen como parte de una
dieta saludable para su corazón las
grasas insaturadas incluyen las grasas
poliinsaturadas y las monoinsaturadas y
se pueden encontrar en alimentos como el
salmón los aguacates las nueces y el
aceite de oliva
y otras decisiones que puede tomar para
un estilo de vida saludable para su
corazón son dejar de fumar y realizar
ejercicios aeróbicos adecuados y de
intensidad moderada caminar montar
bicicleta o nadar 30 minutos al día 5
días a la semana pueden ser una buena
meta de ejercicios hablé con su médico
sobre el tipo de dieta y los planes de
ejercicios más apropiados para su salud
y sus niveles de colesterol
si los cambios en su estilo de vida no
pueden reducir lo suficiente sus niveles
de colesterol su médico puede recetar
les ciertos medicamentos para reducirlo
las estatinas son el medicamento más
común para reducir los niveles de
colesterol ldl o colesterol malo
disminuyendo la cantidad producida por
el hígado no obstante tienen pocos
efectos en la disminución de otro tipo
de grasa en la sangre llamada
triglicéridos y en el aumento del
colesterol bueno también llamado
colesterol de lipoproteína de alta
densidad hdl
su hígado usa colesterol para producir
una sustancia llamada bilis que ayuda a
digerir los alimentos los medicamentos
fijadores de ácido biliar se unen a la
bilis y evitan que se use en la
digestión esto causa que el hígado use
más colesterol para producir más bilis
disminuyendo así la cantidad de
colesterol en su torrente sanguíneo
los inhibidores de absorción de
colesterol bloquean parte del colesterol
capturado en los intestinos y que se
obtiene de los alimentos que consume los
fibratos son principalmente utilizados
para reducir los niveles de
triglicéridos en su sangre pero también
pueden elevar sus niveles de hdl la
niacina reduce el colesterol ldl y los
triglicéridos e incrementa el colesterol
hdl producido en su hígado
los hábitos de estilo de vida saludables
son importantes en el control de sus
niveles de colesterol si su proveedor de
atención médica les recetó medicamentos
para tratar sus niveles altos de
colesterol es importante que los tomes
según se le indicó y que se comunica con
él si tuviera alguna pregunta